deuxième étage du commissariat nord de
bagdad c'est le quartier général de la
brigade de répression du grand
banditisme
depuis quelques mois une section anti
kidnapping a été mise en place au sein
de la brigade c'est le colonel faysal
qui la dirige
pour des raisons de sécurité il ne
témoignera pas à visage découvert
lui c'est l'un des derniers otages
libérés
là c'est un cas qui est toujours en
fuite
ces deux femmes ce sont ses complices
mais lui on va bien finir par l'avoir
regarde bien ce visage
cela ils ont déjà quitté le commissariat
maintenant ils attendent leur procès en
prison
combien vous avez arrêté depuis la
création de la brigade on a démantelé à
peu près une trentaine de gangs
comme journée déjà dit chaque don compte
au minimum trois personnes une centaine
d'arrestations mais seulement quelques
libération d'otages et surtout beaucoup
d'affaires qui tourne mal
regardez lui on l'a libéré in extremis
il est par ses ravisseurs
là c'est une famille entière qui est 12
personnes c'est nous qui les avons
découverts
ces photos c'est nous qui les avons
prises
chaque suspect est photographié fichés
et puis il ya ces documents considérés
comme des pièces à conviction ici en
irak les interrogatoires filmé
au nom de dieu le miséricordieux
nous allons vous présenter le témoignage
du membre d'un groupe qui affirme au
combattre au nom du tout
ce groupe a enlevé et des membres de la
police et de la garde nationale
c'est la première fois que le ministère
de l'intérieur irakien accepte de
dévoiler certains de ces interrogatoires
des images très dures où l'on tente de
faire craquer un suspect en le
confrontant aux images de cette présumée
vous présenter cet homme nous dire qu'il
a et pourquoi at il été
cet homme est un chrétien et il a une
femme et deux enfants
cet anime sentent ils l'ont soupçonnées
d'espionner pour le compte des
américains
combien de personnes environ le groupe
atic
environ 5 à 6 personnes monsieur
le détenu est contraint de regarder la
vidéo de
de l'otage des méthodes que le co n'a
fait ça l'approuvent
avant tu es puni de la prison à vie mais
aujourd'hui c'est la peine de pour les
kidnappeurs
quand tu étais avec eux pendant ces
enlèvements les otages étaient en sus et
toi tu voyais tout ça
ils ont amené tous les jours cinq ou six
pour les pourquoi ne tue pas présenté
aux autorités pour les dénoncer au
début je pensais qu'on se battait pour
le retour au pouvoir du parti baas je ne
pensais pas qu'ils allaient des gens
s'étaient groupe des anciens des
combattants ready quel autre encore
non monsieur s'étaient tous d'anciens
fedayines de saddam hussein je les
connais tous depuis longtemps mais quand
j'étais avec eux je n'avais pas le droit
de les approcher ni même de leur parler
officiellement il y aurait aujourd'hui
près de 200 personnes prises en otage en
irak à la brigade anti rab on estime
qu'il y en aurait peut-être deux fois
plus
[Musique]
l'inspecteur omar a 35 ans et déjà plus
de 15 ans d'expérience au sein de la
police irakienne après la chute de
l'ancien régime il a été sélectionné et
formé par des policiers américains du
fbi haye pour intégrer la brigade anti
rapt de bagdad
il est toujours chargée
oui toujours prêt
s'il te plaît ne filme pas mon visage je
ne veux pas qu'on me voit à la
télévision
ltd quoi as tu peur
j'ai reçu beaucoup de menaces à la
maison et j'ai déjà déménagé à plusieurs
reprises j'ai aussi changé de voiture
ma femme je les envoyer chez ses parents
je ne dors jamais au même endroit
même là j'ai peur pour moi il peut
arriver n'importe quoi la vie
aujourd'hui c'est
[Musique]
quand on est dans un embouteillage comme
ça on n'est pas tranquille il faut que
la route soit dégagée pour pouvoir
rouler vite si on reste trop longtemps
arrêté on devient une cible idéale pour
les
coincer com ou dans l'embouteillage des
militaires pour tenter de se frayer un
passage
effectivement dans ces cas là tout le
monde ne pense plus qu'à une chose se
dégager au plus vite
amber maintenant
là on va passer devant l'endroit où a
disparu la journaliste française c'est
juste à côté du palais des congrès
voilà c'est là qu'on l'a vu pour la
dernière fois
il ya beaucoup de policiers ici
oui il ya beaucoup de police ici c'est
censé être un des endroits les mieux
gardés de la ville
les policiers sont juste là oui
tellement fort
mais tu sais le problème c'est dans ce
genre d'endroit que c'est le plus
dangereux
c'est là que les risques de entre les
policiers les deux sont les plus grands
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur florence aubenas on a un coût
d'information on a contacté à plusieurs
reprises l'ambassade de france mais ils
ne veulent pas de notre aide ils n'ont
même pas voulu nous donner une photo de
la journaliste
les autorités françaises ne sont pas les
seuls à décliner l'offre de services de
la brigade anti rapt à bagdad tout le
monde pense que les gang de kidnappeurs
ont des complices au sein de la police
il ya beaucoup de ce quartier oui il y
en a eu plusieurs récemment là juste là
où la voiture est arrêtée et la mercedes
blanche c'est là qu'il est un enfant
ou si c'est passé juste la
police non ils ne nous ont même pas
prévenu
parmi les dizaines d'enlèvements qui ont
eu lieu dans ce quartier réservé à la
haute bourgeoisie nous allons vous
raconter l'histoire de khalid hamdani
dix ans pour conjurer le sort la famille
hamdani avait mis un oeil sur son
portail est aussi l'empreinte d'une main
pour porter chance mais cela n'a pas
suffi pas plus que son appartenance à
une des plus grandes tribus sunnites du
pays
bientôt trois mois que wright a été
libéré mais chaque jour à son retour de
l'école sa mère et ses petits frères
l'attendent avec le même pincement au
coeur
le 15 décembre dernier comme à son
habitude la mère de wright demande à son
fils de sortir faire des courses à
l'épicerie du coin
une boîte de sauce tomate pour le dîner
du soir
depuis que c'est arrivé je n'ose même
plus laisser les enfants dans le jardin
on les laisse pas on a peur des
kidnappeurs
raitt a passé trois jours et trois nuits
aux mains de ses ravisseurs
mais là c'est quand il était avec eux
oui et m'ont dit on va faire ta maison
si tu ne nous donne pas le numéro de
téléphone de départs en île mondillon
maison et mon père
est ce que tu as essayé de s'enfuir
au fond de mon coeur je pensais à
m'enfuir mais eux ils étaient toujours
autour de moi il y en avait même un
coucher devant la porte la tête sur
l'oreiller
la télévision était branché sur space
tonnes en permanence moi je regardais
les dessins animés pendant que tous
dormait
quand j'ai été libéré tout le monde est
venu m'embrasser me faire des câlins
[Musique]
oui
quand j'étais à faire tes devoirs est ce
que tu penses encore mais pourquoi elle
m'a envoyé faire cette course je sais
madame est pourquoi
non je ne pense plus à maintenant tu ne
m'en veut plus oui c'est ça tu ne penses
plus mauvais moment je n'y pense plus
combien tu m'aimes
autant que l'univers vraiment je te jure
et moi maintenant je ne quitterai plus
jamais fait ma vie
[Musique]
trois mois après les faits la vie
commence à peine à reprendre son cours
normal chez les âmes damnées
alors c'est ça la fameuse sauce tomate
oui c'est exactement la même maillot
qui est allé la chercher celle là je te
garantis que ça sera plus jamais envie
de le faire
cette sauce
quand il y en a à table ça me rappelle
encore de mauvais souvenirs mais
maintenant j'arrive à en manger
[Applaudissements]
l'oncle de raitt l'aîné de la famille
c'est lui qui a pris en charge les
négociations avec les ravisseurs
il a été notre affaire à nous mêmes que
chez hannah murray pas fait mieux
lui c'est le père de raitt il est encore
trop ébranler psychologiquement pour
pouvoir nous parler
heureusement que son frère l'oncle de
raitt a pris les choses en main au
moment de la négociation de la rançon
au début ils ont demandé 100 mille
dollars pour nous rendre rails
et on a commencé à négocier
ça a duré plus de sept heures
finalement on s'est mis d'accord sur
10000 dollars
racontez moi comment s'est passée la
libération
ils m'ont dit on va le laisser dans la
voiture tout ça ils me l'ont dit par
téléphone on l'amène dans notre voiture
et si de loin il te reconnais tout va
bien s'il ne te reconnais pas alors en
tout
il y avait une petite place qui nous
sépare elmander ils m'ont dit si quand
on passe devant lui tu te met à crier on
te tais toi et ton nom
tu es ce que vous avez vu oreilles se
passait en voiture non je ne vais pas
gelé vu juste quand il m'a plu ils l'ont
déposé derrière moi les vus descendre de
la voiture et elle a démarré c'était une
chèvre les derniers modèles elle était
blanche c'est ça un wright était blanche
et la police vous ne les avez pas la
police qu'elle police
n'est même pas des tailles de président
de la république il ministre la police
c'est elle qui les aident ce sont eux
les criminels
c'est quoi un policier aujourd'hui c'est
un ancien voleur
il profite de la situation il se fait
engager comme ça il peut faire tout ce
qu'il veut
c'est normal ne peut rien faire c'est la
police qui a tous les droits
[Musique]
23h derniers préparatifs pour les hommes
de la brigade anti rate une opération
prévue de longue date deux ont été
localisés dans un des quartiers les plus
dangereux de bagdad
le problème c'est que la mission doit se
faire en coordination avec les policiers
du quartier et à la brigade on ne fait
confiance à personne
là bas on n'obéit à aucun ordre
extérieur cette mission c'est la nôtre
on rentre dans la maison prend les deux
suspects on les met dans la voiture et
on se barre le plus vite possible vous
ne parlez à personne vous n'avez rien à
voir avec les flics locaux le plus
important c'est qu'on fasse attention à
nous
exceptionnellement le clown al faiçal a
accepté que nous accompagnons ces hommes
au cours de l'opération seule consigne
interdiction formelle de leur poser des
questions
direction le quartier de l'unité c'est
un des fiefs de la mafia locale située à
une vingtaine de kilomètres du quartier
général de la brigade anti rapt
trois pick up banalisée pour traverser
la ville
nous roulons à plus de 150 km heure dans
les rues désertes de bagdad
les américains
sauf lorsqu'on croise une patrouille
américaine
avec la guerre ce sont des américains
américains les rebelles même lorsqu'on
met un gyrophare même lorsqu'on est
policier il faut s'arrêter
dès la nuit tombée les américains tirent
sans se massent sur achat sur tout
véhicule en mouvement
quinze minutes plus tard à l'entrée du
quartier de l'unité pas question de
s'aventurer dans le dédale de ruelles
sans et flics locaux ils ne sont pas au
rendez vous chaque minute qui passe
augmente le danger et surtout met en
péril l'opération
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent on peut pas y
aller sans eux j'ai encore essayé de les
appeler
toi garde un oeil sur la route sur rail
et la route tu paies de rien d'autre
allez circule plus vite
le succès de l'opération repose sur
l'effet de surprise
les policiers municipaux vont mettre
plus d'une demi-heure avant d'arriver
et ils ne vont pas s'excuser
le briefing entre les deux corps de
police est tendue il ne dure que
quelques minutes
allez les gars on y va
contrôler nous quittons le point de
rendez-vous avec les policiers locaux où
nous escorte jusqu'à la maison des
suspects
ça y est on est arrivé oui c'est juste
là en fait la planque des kidnappeurs
était à moins de 500 mètres de là il
faudrait un miracle pour qu'il soit
encore chez eux ou la porte
faites gaffe
[Musique]
bon qu'est ce que vous faites là
qui êtes vous
c'est la police 1
[Musique]
ils ont mis un cadenas sur la porte va
passer par le toit
les inspecteurs ne laisse rien au hasard
une cache dans un placard suffit pour
dissimuler un otage comme cela leur est
déjà arrivé ou une trappe sous un lit
n'est pas cette fois
le seul indice ce sont ces veste
d'uniforme peut-être appartiennent tel
un otage à moins que les ravisseurs ne
l'utilisent pour éviter d'être repéré
allez ça sert à rien de rester
ils ont fui bien sûr depuis longtemps
allez on se barre
pourquoi vous avez fait tout ce bordel
on n'a pas appris à respectueux des gens
allez les gars on soit une pièce qu sur
toute la ligne et en plus il ya encore
toute la ville a traversé
s'occupe à temps te concentrer sur la
route recule recule avec le risque de
tomber dans une embuscade à chaque coin
de rue on chez toi
la retraite a un goût amer pour tout le
monde au sein de la brigade ils n'ont
pas de preuve formelle mais ils sont
persuadés que ce sont les policiers
municipaux qui ont prévenu les
kidnappeurs
les flics pourris un tel problème en
irak que les autorités ont décidé de
donner un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière et ceux à grand renfort de
publicité
voici ce que les irakiens ont pu voir
sur la télévision pro gouvernemental le
28 février dernier trois cents policiers
accusés d'avoir enlevé dizaine de
personnes avouent leurs crimes en direct
l'émotion est telle que le lendemain les
familles de victimes viennent faire le
siège du commissariat où sont détenus
les policiers kidnappeurs la
confrontation entre victimes et assassin
va avoir lieu devant les caméras de
télévision
je suis le fils du martyr samir mohammad
haidar il avait le grade de sergent
ce sont des policiers qui n'ont
qu est ce que tu lui reconnaît fait oui
il y en a un parmi eux amènent le
le voilà là bas
c'est lui là
c'est lui c'est lui
c'est toi qui a enlevé son père moi je
les frapper avec ma chaussure il a peur
de parler maintenant parle ces messieurs
le martyr qui a été exécuté c'est
hussein
moi j'étais juste là avec le groupe
quant à ses passages
retour au commissariat de bagdad nord
ces jours d'interrogatoire pour les
prisonniers capturés par la brigade de
répression du grand banditisme
[Musique]
tous sont regroupés dans la même cellule
une pièce d'une centaine de mètres
carrés sans aucune lumière extérieure
certains attendent ici depuis six mois
voilà main armée 3
attaque de banque ils sont en tout une
centaine de prisonniers parmi eux une
trentaine est soupçonné d'avoir
participé
sur ce registre on inscrit le nom de
tous les nouveaux détenus si un détenu a
été libéré on marque qu'il l'a été même
chose s'il a été transféré vers une
autre prison pour envoyer chez le juge
et
la nouvelle vient de tomber à la
télévision
contre une caserne de policiers à hilla
à une trentaine de kilomètres de là
c'est là le plus et depuis deux ans
regarde un peu c'est il y avait aussi un
hôpital à côté
ça la libération de notre pays
la brigade anti rapt aussi a eu son lot
de victimes estiment ces deux derniers
mois
les interrogatoires reprennent les
prisonniers aux yeux bandés sont
directement déférer aux américains nous
ne pourrons pas les suivre
en revanche nous allons assister à
l'interrogatoire de quatre prévenus
quatre étudiants soupçonnés d'avoir
enlevé
et peut-être turine de leurs camarades
de l'université parra
ils ont tous été arrêtés en même temps à
la suite d'une lettre de dénonciation
envoyé par la meilleure amie de farah
tous clament leur innocence
hassan est le petit ami de farah lui est
persuadé que toute cette affaire est un
coup monté
quel est ton nom hassan ton nom complet
hassan abou à 1000
elle a disparu le 29 décembre dernier et
ses parents ont attendu deux mois pour
la signaler quelle preuve vous avez
qu'on l'a enlevé on l'a trouvée chez
nous quelqu'un nous a vus avec elle on
ne sait même pas où elle habite on ne
connaît même pas son numéro de téléphone
c'est juste parce que sa meilleure amie
envoyé une lettre nous accusant de
l'avoir emmené dans le nord qu'on a été
arrêté
tout ça j'ai déjà expliqué un de vos
collègues et lui il a très bien compris
il m'a même dit qu'il allait convoquer
la fille qui nous a dénoncé
m
on est des étudiants et ont fait
confiance les fausses accusations la
délation font partie du quotidien des
inspecteurs de la brigade anti rate mais
même si les trois quarts de leurs
prisonniers se dit innocent
l'expérience leur a montré qu'il ne
fallait pas se fier aux apparences
exemple avec cet interrogatoire qui sert
aujourd'hui de pièces à conviction dans
le cadre d'une affaire de kidnapping
est-ce que c'est toi qui te fait appeler
à l'ieee bonne amie rhin oui monsieur
ali hibon amira est accusé d'avoir
enlevé et dieu douzaine de personnes au
cours de son interrogatoire il affirme
pourtant être un simple sous fifres
de personnes dans le premier groupe
d'otages que ton quand greg
sa set et dans le deuxième groupe
d'otages
monsieur roch c
est toi c'était quoi ton rôle au sein du
gang
c'était quoi ton rôle
ces femmes chefs qui m'a fait venir de
force il m'a dit qu'il allait me tuer ma
famille si je n'obéissais pas
ensuite il m'a amené à l'endroit où
étaient les otages il m'a dit que moi je
n'aurais rien d'autre à faire qu'à
conduit
après les avoir conduits il m'a donné 4
$ et 8 $ pour conduire le deuxième
groupe d'otages monsieur
ali even amira ce jeune homme soi-disant
forcé de conduire sur leur lieu d ont
des otages innocents bah en fait être
confondu par une de ces
qui t'a fait cette blessure fiston allez
allez ebay caméra un témoignage
bouleversant diffusé à la télévision
irakienne qui servira lui aussi au cours
du procès de l'accusé
comment il t'a blessés il m'a attrapée
et il m'a tiré deux fois dessus il ya
une balle qui m'a frôlé et une autre qui
m'a touché au genou pourquoi c'était
pour que je lui dise où était mon père
c'est lui qui est père oui monsieur tu
l'as vue du père oui monsieur comment il
est dur monsieur d'avoir il a fait mon
père avec sa crosse
après l'avoir cha cross mon père est
tombé par terre
et là il dans la tête
dans le chaos généralisé qui règne à
bagdad difficile de faire la part des
choses entre les non crapuleuses les
actes de vengeance ou les purement
politique et que dire de l'histoire de
fawzia qui elle défie toute logique elle
n'a pratiquement plus de quoi vivre
depuis que son mari simples marchands
ambulants dans les rues de bagdad allez
en fait deux tournées par jour deux
fournées pourquoi nous sommes une grande
famille louvier
nous les femmes on ne mangent que du
pain ça nous suffit
fawzia est bien trop pauvres pour payer
la rançon elle a été fixée à 20 mille
dollars par les ravisseurs quelques
jours après la disparition son mari
depuis plus aucune nouvelle
que se passe-t-il dans ce monde les gens
n'ont rien mais rien pourquoi c'est
comme ça pourquoi ya pas de sécurité il
n'y a rien pour nous les journalistes ce
qu'on vaut les kidnapper
ceux qui ont des voitures sont rodés un
autre se fait un épicier se fait
dévaliser mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ça on est sorti du ont tombé dans une
autre nous on jouait la sécurité on veut
vivre enfin toutes ces choses là - la
vieille match je peux même pas aller
dehors il dit il te dévalisé le coup je
sais pas quoi encore voilà au moins
j'aurais dit ce que j'avais à dire
fawzia a bien tenté d'aller voir la
police locale mais avant même de
commencer à enquêter eux aussi lui ont
demandé de l'argent résigné désormais
n'attend plus qu'un miracle
nous demandons à dieu dieu tout puissant
qu'il nous préserve il nous accorde sa
miséricorde
qu'il fasse que la police soit la
hauteur et nous apporte enfin à la
sécurité dans ce pays
que dieu nous protège
[Musique]
pauvres riches étrangers journalistes
professeurs médecins avocats kurdes
chrétiens chiites sunnites
aujourd'hui les enlèvement peuvent
arriver n'importe où et à n'importe qui
à bagdad
on